Yan welcome to St Louis welcome to Grand
Tour it's it's great to see you here
again how did you feel when you came
back here after more than one year and
what was your initial reaction when you
came to the hotel to the club uh well
it's good to see the club finally
renovated I think uh it took took a
while so last year it was everything was
like a little bit of mess so another
entrance another door another another
room another everything
uh okay this year it looks like uh the
job's done or or maybe I I haven't been
to you know everywhere just here so for
now but I hope
so uh and uh yeah it's finally it's
finally chance to see uh the city you
know
and uh just not um not you know in the
midsummer when it's like a little bit
too hot but in November so it's um you
know it's still warm enough but uh you
know I expect I expected to to get a
little bit Frosty uh closer to the end
of the tournament yeah like end of
November but for now yeah it's um it's
very fine so finally it's uh no hit but
just some normal average average
temperature yeah yeah that's true and uh
speaking about your GCT situation you
played in the tournaments in Romania
then in Croatia so where are you now and
where do you want to get you tell me I
you know I never that's maybe that's
maybe the problem with my overall
results but you know I never check the
standings of the gcd tour I know other
guys do and they play for for result but
I just play you know for no no let's say
not for fun but yeah for for some
experience for some excitement but uh
yeah I think I'm doing not that bad uh
you know if not a tournament in
Bucharest I would be doing like nice I
think because it was like some second
place in Croatia but uh yeah well where
where do you want to get let's say the
second part well I I want to win but you
know it's I always want to win but
what's I I don't think it depends only
on me sometimes it doesn't but last year
actually you came very close you were
second and chances yeah yeah thank you
for thank you for reminding that's
very uh you know very hard forming very
touching of few yes of course I mean
sorry to to remind you about this it was
really special event in any case and
which synful cup which GCT event was the
most memorable for you I guess uh I
guess London
2017 uh then um uh you know I had no
hopes for for anything but then suddenly
okay I won three in a row and yeah if
only if only Mickey Adams would accept a
threefold repetition at some point
against Fabby it would be uh would be a
very fine event to to win but then okay
it came uh to TI breaks and then okay
Fabby uh surprisingly after 6 hours
games 6our game was more fresh than me
uh who was watching this six hour
game yeah but anyway any that was like
um a good event but uh yeah normally I I
expect you know every next event to be
better you yeah maybe let's see what
happens this year but let's speak a
little bit about something else that
idat tournament because everybody is
talking about it you know the GCT event
is also part of this F circuit and few
players are still fighting for the spot
so but I'm not fighting for the spot so
I don't care that you're not yes I know
you're there already but I think you you
would keep an eye on the others and in
general what do you think about the
field already I mean we know some names
and whom do you prefer to see in the
candidates tournament from those who are
playing here it's Wesley Anish and I
think Al are still fighting I don't know
it's uh I guess any any of this three is
like quite a formidable opponent so
it's uh you never know until until the
tournament starts who's like in good
shape who is like H is not so well
prepared yet so we'll see
but for C current situation I
think uh Anish and uh Anish is on the
second place have slightly better
chances yeah than Wesley um Wesley is on
the short Place ah yeah Wesley yeah but
Wesley is still in the competition yeah
and you know when the tournament is
important he always you know tries to
show his best so okay let's see let's
grab some popcorn for sure but you're
still playing here and you will play in
the candidates you won two previous ones
and are you ready to repeat the
success what you doing for it know I
absolutely I don't
mind uh but that's you know it's once
again it depends on
manufacturers yeah so first of all um
who's playing when is the you know when
is the tournament where is the
tournament yes so it's uh will I make it
to Canada yeah like getting my Visa or
not so about it also quite um quite a
question yeah to be honest so yeah you
know let's see but um I guess uh you
know playing a couple of matches leaves
you with some nice amount of
preparation uh but um anyway anyway even
having like this uh you know big luggage
you still have to
you know to work and to prepare so
there's always something to prepare for
yeah yeah yeah and I wish you to play
well in the tournament so the best of
luck for you thank you for the interview
thank you